and if dr paulson can be available and
go ahead and come on screen
he is an associate professor in the
departments of computer and information
sciences plant and soil sciences and
biological sciences at the university of
delaware
his research interests lie at the
intersection of genomics and microbial
ecology examining the ways in which
microorganisms and their viruses affect
and are affected by their environments
in light of covid and other viruses this
could be a very relevant topic for a
world
dr polson you are on the stage
all right great and can everyone hear me
everything i can hear you fine and your
presentation is showing fine so it's all
excellent
all right well thank you to the
organizers for the invitation to talk
today um i put together a talk that
dives a little bit into my research and
actually
kind of looks at a bioinformatics
education thread with undergraduates
that has kind of
shaped my research program over the
years and we'll get into that in a
little more detail
but as grant mentioned i
am at the university of delaware and i
wear a few hats there
in addition to you know my faculty role
i'm also a director of
bioinformatics core facility and the
bioinformatics and data science core
aspect of the delaware embry program so
i work with investigators pretty much
across the swath of
biomedical data science and
bioinformatics in trying to figure out
how to
interpret data that they have
how to actually move forward their
research using
uh different tools and and how to
educate people in bioinformatics so a
lot of what
we saw in our last talk is was great uh
really kind of hit the nail on the head
with
a lot of the topics that i'm usually
talking about in my presentations
so
i i as i said i'm going to talk a little
bit about my science today but i did
want to briefly mention kind of our our
bioinformatics data science
infrastructure at the university of
delaware i think the university of
delaware was really forward-looking
about 15 to 20 years ago and making a
really big investment in bringing in a
strong bioinformatics aspect to the
campus
and one of the unique aspects our
bioinformatics programs have is that our
campus you know we are not uh associated
with a medical school which actually
means that we have a lot of life science
uh
uh research that is going on that is not
only in the biomedical sphere but goes
beyond that to agriculture uh biopharma
bioengineering chemical engineering so
there are just tons of related
disciplines that end up feeding into our
bioinformatics center
that i am part of so we have we have a
really vibrant kind of population of
people that are interested in omics data
science broadly um and
uh our center which uh you know has been
uh around for about 15 years now uh is
is both uh holding those core facilities
that i mentioned that i host and also a
really strong educational program
um where we've developed a number of
different graduate degrees in
bioinformatics data sciences
that you know we we have
dozens hundreds at this point of
students have passed through our various
graduate certificates
master's programs and of course doctoral
level programs
and
we're really engaged in education
throughout that entire that entire realm
um but one thing i did want to include
in this talk is we are really excited
that you know our already what we feel
like are really good bioinformatics
education programs have just gotten a
huge boost from an nih investment
which i am lead pi on this new t32
graduate training grant in computational
biology bioinformatics and biomedical
data sciences that we're going to be
hosting at the university of delaware
and actually just gave the launch uh
orientation for that a couple of days
ago and we're really excited about the
opportunity to bring this in
it comes with a number of new uh you
know slots for students that we can
fund and bring into our program but also
is going to let us really work in those
kind of interesting experiences with
working with industry working with
government and working with people in
the medical industry
as well so i just want to put in a plug
for this we are
you know recruiting for our next cohort
starting next year anybody is interested
in our program uh please feel free to to
reach out to us at the bioinformatics
uw.edu email address
so without further ado on to the
research talk that i want to give for
today
um
so
my entire career has been you know based
around looking at microbes and what they
do
um and i think you know we've seen in
the past you know decade or so that
the the the role of microbes the
microbiome associated with humans and
other organisms they really started to
take a much more central role than they
ever had in the past
so i i if we look at this kind of extent
of genetic diversity on earth
and we look at this tree here you can
see that
this little red circle at the bottom
pretty much every organism that you can
see with your eye is within that red
circle all the rest of this diversity
it's microorganisms from bacteria to
archaea to microbial eukaryotes so it's
really is a you know it's a it's a
microbial world i don't think this is
any secret uh but even this uh tree does
not capture that full extent there's
obviously one missing piece what is it
um well it's viruses right
so
viruses obviously have been very much in
our consciousness than the last couple
of years with uh the covet epidemic
um but i tend to to research more on a
different group of viruses
which are the the microbial viruses
which would be any virus that infects
one of those microorganisms that i
mentioned
uh and these are you know by far the
most diverse group of biological
entities on the planet the the
if there is a gene on this planet
probably a microbial virus is carrying
around some version of that gene
um and they are probably one of the most
poorly or least poorly understood groups
of or of you know biological entities i
always hasten to call them
organisms
on the planet and
that's a lot of what my research has
been based around is how to figure out
ways to understand viruses and how they
impact their environment
so
i i have a joint research group here at
the university of delaware i've actually
teamed up with two other faculty members
eric womack and jeff furman and we've
you know developed a joint group that
looks at different aspects of these
virus microbe
environment interactions in that
environment really it could be anything
um you know i've looked at this is just
a small selection of things i have
looked at
but it could be anything from you see
seagrass here coral seawater
but also humans right humans are an
environment and a major environment for
microbes so looking at humans and
biomedical models agricultural models
you can see soybean here
these are the types of projects we do
but what unifies them is this interest
in the microorganisms
how those microorganisms interact with
these either environments or are
eukaryotic organisms
and then ultimately how the viruses that
infect those microbes uh play into that
so it's kind of a tripartite system
we're looking at
and to to study this you know obviously
dna you know those types of omics
techniques are the bread and butter of
looking at these types of systems uh so
those are really kind of the unifying
themes that go through my research
so
you know just as a basic background
viruses are really difficult to study if
you can go out and isolate a virus and
sequence this genome you know you're
golden you can do a lot of research with
it but it is very very hard to do that
even when we know what the host is say
human it is often very difficult to go
out and find specific viruses that are
infecting that host much less if you're
looking at environmental samples where
there could be thousands of potential
hosts and thousands or tens of thousands
of different types of viruses and
figuring out which virus goes with which
host and what can you host can you
culture the host can you culture the
virus
so there's a there's a lot of
complexity in trying to study viruses
so dna-based methods have really become
important for looking at viruses however
a lot of the tools that allow us to use
uh omix-based techniques and other
organisms like marker genes that are
universal say the 16s rna gene that gets
used in bacteria don't exist in viruses
there is no one gene that every virus
has
so
it makes it quite difficult quite quite
complex to look at
so using shotgun metagenomics which you
know would be going out into an
environment taking a sample that has a
broad mixture of organisms in it
typically what we'll do is we will
filter out the cellular organisms into a
separate fraction so that what's left is
just things of a size that should be
viruses
and then we sequence that entire sample
right so we get a huge amount of dna
sequencing data back and it's about many
many many different types of viruses
that might be living in an individual
sample
so then we use various techniques to go
through and look at that and some of
those techniques can be quite
computationally expensive uh but you
know as computing and other technologies
have advanced that's really not a
limiting factor in doing these types of
of techniques at this point at this
point really our limiting factor is our
ability to make biological
interpretations out of those genomic
data that we get i'd say in viruses it's
really hard because as i mentioned you
can't culture many of them so for us to
actually have phenotypes in the viruses
that we could potentially correlate with
things we're seeing genotypically in
that metagenomic data it becomes a real
challenge for us
so
you know
other other issues that we run into are
things like if we look at any given
environment and we metagenomically
sequence it and then we cluster all the
putative proteins that are there
and we look at them
from the most common to the least common
among the most common proteins one study
we have here we found that 62 of the 100
most abundant putative proteins were
uncharacterized
and of the ones which is saying they
were not in a genome at that point
and of the ones that were actually in a
genome all the ones that have arrows
pointing to them here were you know they
were annotated as puted of
uncharacterized protein which might as
well be
uncharacterized uh or are unknown uh for
for all intensive purposes so this is a
major wall we also run into is that you
know there's a lot of genomic data out
there but we don't even know what gene
it corresponds to so much less what type
of activity it may have
so it's been an ongoing challenge and
probably one of the things that keeps me
interested in this work uh is that it's
challenging to go through these data and
figure out ways to make meaningful
biological conclusions based on them
uh so i mentioned you know undergraduate
researchers have played a huge role in
shaping this research program
and this is a this is actually a slide
from about 11 years ago this is a
program that we've had going on for
quite a while
but what we started to do
with my collaborators was to
each summer recruit a cohort of
undergraduate researchers into the lab
and we're lucky to have excellent summer
undergraduate research programs at the
university of delaware that have helped
us to do this and to bring these
students in
and we really put them to work on doing
metagenomic analysis on doing some of
the lab-based steps downstream of it
so that we can start to understand a
little bit more about this diversity
that is out there
so one of the main approaches we've used
with them is we will you know we'll take
these protein clusters that we see in
metagenomes we'll have them explore them
we'll have them
adopt a particular cluster or a
particular type of cluster i have
ribonucleotide reductase clusters kind
of pointed out in this graph here
so
one undergraduate researcher may take
these and they will they will actually
go through the metagenomic data pull out
the sequence reads for those uh those
that contain those genes
do assemblies
do phylogenetic analyses ultimately
build some primers so that they could
look at this and try to actually
identify it in environmental samples and
then you know take some environmental
samples that we have in our library and
see if they can actually re-identify
these genes in those
natural samples and through doing this
it really increased our bandwidth to be
able to look at all that metagenomic
data that we were holding on to and
really start to understand some of these
genes that we see very commonly in uh
the the various metagenome sequences and
you know i i we've definitely looked at
both unknown and known uh functional
genes through these types of methods and
we have interesting stories on both
today i'm going to follow through with
one story that is from a known gene
which would be dna polymerase one
so if you're not familiar it is the
proofreading polymerase of many bacteria
but in
viruses that carry out it it is the main
polymerase it is the one they use for
replicating their genome
and it is a fairly common gene for a
double-stranded dna virus to carry we
see it in about 25
of known dna viruses double-stranded dna
viruses so that's actually a pretty good
percentage for us so looking at this
gene gives us the ability to look across
a lot of different viruses
so
one group that has looked at this and
there are a couple of grad students just
chopic and dan nasco
also eric sakowski who's not on here and
in particular one undergrad helen
schmidt
who really adopted this dna polymerase
gene over the course of several years
and made some really interesting
discoveries with it that i wanted to
walk you through
so
uh first is a little bit of background
to remind you
viruses and microbial viruses in
particular tend to come in two
lifestyles or flavors
um there are the viruses that will enter
a cell and immediately they're going to
go into the replicative cycle make a lot
of copies of themselves and immediately
lyse the cell so those are the ones that
are virulent or litholite the lytic
lifestyle by default
the other group are the temperate phage
or temperate viruses those are the ones
that enter the cell incorporate
themselves into the host genome
will lie dormant for some period of time
and then eventually some trigger in the
cell or the cell's environment will
cause it to essentially activate itself
and then do a replication so
understanding which viruses are lytic
and lysogenic
is a pretty pretty important thing when
you're trying to understand viral
biology and how viruses impact their
host
so
it seems like this would be a very easy
thing to identify within a sequence but
it's not always and actually many many
many phage that are out there we have
complete genome sequences but we still
don't know for sure which one of these
lifestyles
those phage tend to follow
so
helen schmidt as i mentioned she was a
undergraduate biochemistry major
and she came into one of our summer
undergraduate internship
opportunities and adopted this dna
polymerase one
cluster and started looking at it in
much more detail
and through her work and her particular
interest in biochemistry
she noticed something within this gene
that
has led to 12 years of subsequent
research for us
and that was the fact that within this
gene when you look at the the protein
sequence for it there is an individual
amino acid residue within it that seems
to be predictive for the phage lifestyle
if we look at this
residue at position 762 relative to the
e coli version of the gene
the the default that you tend to see in
bacteria is a phenylalanine at that
position
however if tyrosine is at that position
there is biochemical data out there that
indicates that that makes the polymerase
about a thousand times more processive
faster
essentially but also makes it more prone
to errors while it's replicating
um there's also a mutation that's been
biochemically characterized to leucine
at that location and when that amino
acid is in there we get about three
times more accurate but about a thousand
times slower than the phenylalanine
so it's quite a spread in the speed and
the accuracy that occurs
based on this one amino acid change in
polymerases and what helen noticed was
that this individual amino acid residue
when she overlaid its identity onto a
tree
very neatly clades with our groups with
the clades that were on the tree we can
cleanly see there are two groups here
that are losing but there's a single
group each for phenylalanine and
tyrosine so to us that was an indication
wow there is a real
uh biological
phenomenon going on with this amino acid
residue
and we really saw that when she started
to look at the lifestyle of the phage
that we did know their um their
lifestyle and that was that the the
tyrosine version was always lytic we had
no exceptions at the time of a lysogenic
uh phage that had tyrosine phenylalanine
was almost always lytic a few exceptions
there
and leucine was almost always lysogenic
so just this individual residue gave us
that information that otherwise is very
very difficult for us to identify out of
these types of sequences
so if we just do the thought of
experiment of why this might be
important to viral biology
let's think about you know lydic viruses
are the ones that come into their host
they replicate fast they produce lots of
copies of themselves and then they're
out of the cell
so for those guys if they have errors in
a few copies
maybe that's okay maybe occasionally
you're going to get a mutant and maybe
that mutant is actually a good thing
right maybe that's new diversity that's
going to allow them to succeed but if
that mutant actually is bad then you
know
it it's okay you've got lots of copies
that are faithful to the original
um
you know and occasionally you're gonna
get a really crazy mutation which uh you
know may may or may not be a good thing
uh but you have to see how that works
out with natural selection but the
really interesting thing with this trait
is you're you're modifying your
polymerase and your polymerase is
ultimately responsible for the mutations
that could lead to natural selection
lead to evolution so really by modifying
their polymerase in this way or you know
naturally selecting for the polymerase
in this way they're evolving to increase
the rate of of evolution which you know
that's a phenomenal thought right
they're they're they're really giving
themselves the ability to be more
diverse
if we look at the other side of the of
the coin temperate phage tend to
replicate slower they're sitting within
their cell for a long time so they
really need to be more in sync with the
cell and then when they actually do
start to replicate themselves they're
doing it at a critical time when there's
probably a stress on the cell and they
really need to get accurate copies and
get out so that they can survive and
reinfect a new cell so
in those phage you know selecting for a
more accurate mutation this leucine
mutation even though it's a bit slower
may have significant evolutionary uh of
potential for you know keeping it in
sync with its host
so for the rest of my talk uh actually
one more slide on this so you know the
the first students i talked about they
were doing that process that whole
process very manually we've actually
since done a lot of work on streamlining
it making it easier building
bioinformatics tools i've had a number
of grad students who have come through
and we've just made an entire suite of
bioinformatics tools that make this
process of investigating these viral
genes in this way uh very
straightforward
and easy to do
so
for the rest of the talk if we go back
to this dna polymerase a you know we
we've looked at plenty of other clusters
but this one has really been one that
has really captured our our interest
uh and i i mentioned this this thousand
times faster but not quite as accurate
or three times more accurate and a
thousand times slower
those are really you know fairly
widespread in biochemical literature but
when we really traced it back they all
went back to single studies where they
tried some in vitro
mutations so really we didn't know for
sure that all polymerases followed this
rule or that it's something we would
actually see in the environment
so a current study we have ongoing now
is actually taking the bioinformatics
back into the lab
and i have a student rachel keown
who's
been working with some collaborators at
virgin biosciences and what we've done
is actually taken our metagenomic
sequences for dna polymerase a
and have picked out different variants
of them across the tree represent these
different types of amino acid residues
that come from different sources and
we've had them synthesized had the dna
synthesized and then cloned those into
expression vectors so that we can
actually produce the protein and do
biochemical characterizations of it
so
this was something a little bit out of
our wheelhouse and we were really hoping
it was going to work and fortunately you
know working with these experts at
virgin
it's working we have actually taken
we've had about 50 of these synthesized
at this point and we've had about a 60
success rate of being able to isolate a
protein out of it and that protein
actually having functionality
so
you know it's really cool that we can
actually take a sequence from a
metagenome and make a protein out of it
but what we're ultimately interested in
is we want to find viral phenotypes and
the biochemistry of these enzymes
ultimately determine how fast that virus
can replicate how fast it can copy
itself and get out of its host cell
so understanding the different
phenotypes biochemically for this enzyme
is something really important that we
can now layer on to other data that we
have so
you know i i won't go into explaining
this figure because i'm getting a little
short on time but the the bottom line is
if we look through uh these different
ones that we have synthesized we have
found quite a few of them that we can
show have primer extension activity at
various speeds to various rates
we also have several of them that have a
strand displacement activity which is an
interesting activity uh on its own um
that our by our our partners in industry
are very interested in but we also are
interested in is that it's another
phenotype that that organism has or that
virus has that it's carrying around that
we can potentially look at
so rachel is moving forward with this
work
she's gone a little bit beyond only
looking at this biochemical data that
she's been producing but she's also
looked more at
what else goes with the polymerase it's
not living in a vacuum it's ultimately
working with other genes to replicate
the genome
and we really see that there are some
really constant associations between our
different tyrosine pulley phenylalanine
pulley leucine pulley with different
types of helicase genes that are
specifically tuned to work with
individual ones so this is another piece
of evidence that this processivity
accuracy
hypothesis that we've been testing may
well be true in that
gp4 helicases for instance are known to
be among the fastest helicases out there
and if you're unwinding the dna for a
very fast polymerase you would think
you're going to need a very fast
helicase
so that we're seeing these associations
is very promising and we're now starting
to move beyond the pole a and also look
at the biochemistry of these accessory
genes like helicases like ribonucleotide
reductases
that we see in association with these
and look at that broader genome net
neighborhood and figure out how that
module of genome actually impacts the
biology of the phage
so where are we going with this work um
you know ultimately rachel's still
working on purifying and biochemically
characterizing those various enzymes
she's worked with another group of
undergraduates this summer in doing
optimal ph and temperature assays
which can actually tell us a little bit
about the biology of the cells that the
phage are infecting based on where their
optimal amplification or where their
optimal operational temperatures and phs
may fall
as we're expanding this database of
biochemical information about different
phage from different phylogenetic parts
of the tree
we're correlating that data with other
information that we're we either have
based on where they were isolated or
abundance and infectivity information
that we're we're producing in other
areas of our lab
through various collaborations and our
ultimate goal here is we're going to
take this massive data both on
biochemistry observable phenotypes when
we can get them as well as the genotypic
features that seem to correlate with
these and we're going to integrate them
together and begin to
see if we can make models that will
allow us to predict phenotype more
accurately based on the genotypic
features that we've seen within these
replication module proteins
and how well it can interpret or
predict these types of infectivity
characteristics or environmental
characteristics
that may apply and we've done this on
some fairly simple basis so far just
looking at combinations of
ribonucleotide reductases and dna
polymerases that we see occurring
together and we've actually had some
really interesting
results come out of that where we can
see correlations between
versions of ribonucleotide reductase
that require oxygen versus don't require
oxygen and the the available oxygen or
metal cofactors
that are available in their system
so we have some great preliminary data
here and we're really hoping to build a
more
substantial model moving forward
with our work
so i think i am wrapped up now um thanks
to everyone in my lab and my
collaborators and of course our funding
sources
thank you dr paulson that is again
fascinating stuff if you don't mind you
can quit sharing your screen so we can
see you
how are these in silico tools like alpha
fold for research you're working on how
useful are they
they're actually quite useful i actually
have a grad student uh zach schreiber
and a collaborator marty belcade at the
university of hawaii and they are
looking at particularly at protein
structure uh that we can predict with
these new and silico alpha fold two and
so forth uh and how well that can be
used to classify these proteins and
metagenomes so that's that's actually a
different direction we're going but it
is something we are investigating in
this area
very fascinating how important is
mentorship and student participation in
this research you've mentioned a whole
bunch of names that aren't yours during
this
yeah absolutely so you know student
participation is you know our research
could not happen without it both
undergrads and grads and we really try
to set up a kind of a a group support
mechanism we don't just take an
individual student through we bring
through a cohort of students which
brings a support mechanism with it in
itself and then we pair those students
those undergraduates with graduate
students and then we have mentor pi
meetings with them on a regular basis
so through that kind of multi-level
mentoring
it both teaches graduate students to be
mentors but it also sets up multiple
levels of support for those students as
they move forward
to to you know get get at these types of
new skills that they're trying to to
learn and apply
thank you so much
i've wrapped up our time with you and we
really appreciate that i think we could
ask questions for another half hour if
we could but we need to move on so thank
you again for your participation here
this afternoon we really appreciate it
thank you thank you